we know hogwarts legacy takes place in
the late 1800s so using that information
we can actually find out some famous
witches and wizards that might be in the
game that's right thanks to all the old
video games and those famous witch and
wizard cards plus the actual physical
witch and wizard cards that were
released we can actually use the
information and the dates on those to
work backwards and see who just might be
in hogwarts legacy of course we're
working with that broad late 1800s time
frame so for the purposes of this video
i'm gonna assume that as anywhere past
1850 so let's start right off the jump
with the two most obvious ones gellert
grindelwald and albus dumbledore
dumbledore was born in 1881 grindelwald
was born just two years later in 1883.
of course we know grindelwald did not
attend hogwarts so we won't be seeing
him there however he was expelled from
durmstrang and would later visit
godric's hollow and that's where he
struck up the friendship with albus
dumbledore dumbledore of course did
attend hogwarts and was known as one of
the brightest wizards even in his
younger days and it's only just recently
that i have went back and looked at this
screenshot right here and if you zoom in
on this character over here in the
bottom left i don't know maybe i'm crazy
but to me that looks like it could very
well be a young alba stomador remember
when he was young he had auburn hair of
course this area is a little bit dark
over here but that really looks like it
is auburn hair and of course he has the
glasses as well so by being born in 1881
that means he would start hogwarts
around 1892.
so it all depends on just how late we
are starting in the late 1800s as to
whether or not we will actually see
albus dumbledore in the game look if
hogwarts legacy takes place at all
around 1892 or a couple years after
dumbledore will absolutely be in the
game that's something that is so glaring
there's no way they would leave that out
so as with most things we'll just have
to wait and see okay now that we've
gotten the big two out of the way i want
to go to another one who i think would
be absolutely insane and quite
terrifying if they feature him in
hogwarts legacy it is none other than
sir herbert varney who lived from 1858
to
1889 and he was actually a famous
victorian vampire who prayed exclusively
upon women specifically in the 1880s in
london he was actually captured and
killed by a special squad from the
department for the regulation and
control of magical creatures so even if
this isn't something that we actually
see happen or who knows maybe we even
take part in it regardless i think it's
definitely something that we could be
hearing about while we're attending
hogwarts a conveyor will see that being
a conversation among the kids as maybe
they're reading the daily prophet one
day and come across the fact that he has
been captured and killed now let's take
a look at these other witch and wizards
who are found on the famous witch and
wizard cards beatrix bloxham was born in
1794 and died in 1910 and she is the
author of the toadstool tales series of
children's books she did have her own
wizard card i was actually featured a
couple of times in tales of beetle the
bard but what's crazy about her story is
that the books were banned because they
have been known to cause nausea and
vomiting and see it's little things like
this that could sprinkle their way into
hogwarts legacy that would really make
the world feel alive and feel authentic
to the wizarding world up next we have
alberik grunion who was born in 1803 and
lived to
1882. grunion invented the dung bomb so
it's safe to say that we will most
likely have access to dung bombs in
hogwarts legacy if you remember grunion
is actually one of the very first wizard
cards that harry potter received in
sorcerer's stone after that we have
crispin crunk who was born in 1795 and
lived to 1872. now cronk was warned by
the ministry of magic repeatedly to not
keep sphinxes in his backyard he never
listened and eventually went to azkaban
for it now we know there's that shot of
azkaban in the trailer with the
dementors could we possibly stumble
across crispin cronk if we go there
again it all comes back to the date
though because he died in 1872 so
anywhere after that and we wouldn't be
seeing him there dorcas well beloved was
born in 1812 and lived to 1904 and she
was the founder of the society for
distressed witches now what's
interesting about her time frame right
here is regardless this firmly puts her
as definitely being alive in hogwarts
legacy so the question is will this
society for distressed witches come to
play in the game at some point this next
one though is arguably even more
interesting it is grogan stump who lived
from 1770 to 1884. now if stump rings a
bell to you it's because he was a very
popular minister for magic who served
from 1811 to 1819 so he's not going to
be minister of magic in the game however
he had a lot to do with the department
of magical games and sports there's a
little bit of a discrepancy as whether
he's the one who established it or if he
just re-established it but in addition
to that he also passed very important
legislation regarding creatures and
beings in the wizarding world now for
any of you who have been following this
channel for a while you guys know that i
think magical creatures other magical
beings and their rights or how those
magical creatures are treated is gonna
play a huge role in the game so it's
interesting that while he was minister
he passed very important legislation
regarding this which means in hogwarts
legacy we're going to be seeing the
after effects of that so what happened
after he passed this important
legislation moving on next we have
hesper starkey from 1881 to 1973 she was
a witch who studied the use of phases of
the moon in potion making now right when
i hear 1881 i immediately think back to
albus dumbledore so she would be roughly
the same age as dumbledore so if
dumbledore is in the game if we are in
school around that 1892 time frame then
we very well could come across hesper
starkey as well as dumbledore and
speaking of magical creatures there's
also been a lot of talk of whether or
not werewolves will be in the game this
would be another interesting way to pull
in that character here if there actually
is a werewolf in the game maybe it's a
fellow student that we're working with
and we come across starkey who's gonna
help us make a potion who could perhaps
help our friend i don't know this one
doesn't specifically mention werewolves
that just mentioned phases of the moon
but still that could be an interesting
connection up next we have justice
hillywickl who was born in 1862 and
lived to 1953. we don't know a whole lot
about piliwickel other than he was a
former head of the department of magical
law enforcement the next character here
is laverne dey montmorency hope i'm
pronouncing that correct she was born in
1823 and lived to 1893. now she was
confirmed to attend hogwarts around 1834
until 1841. so this is not a character
that we would be coming across in game
again if they stick to that late 1800s
time frame however she is an adult
character that we could possibly meet in
some of our adventures now her big claim
to fame love potions so it's safe to say
that love potions will have been created
by that late 1800s time frame it just
remains to be seen if they'll feature in
the game at all leo paulina smithwick
was born in 1829 and lived to 1910 she
became the first witch to referee a
quidditch match another bizarre one is
mirabella plunkett she was born in 1839
we don't know when she died or even if
she died why you may ask well she
actually fell in love with a merman
while on holiday turns out her family
forbade her to marry him so she
transfigured herself into a haddock and
was never seen again norvel twonk was
born in 1888 lived to 1957. he actually
died while heroically saving a muggle
child from a manticore and a famous
wizard card was created in his honor
this next one here is another i think
personally a big one for hogwarts legacy
oswald beamish who lived from 1850 to
1935 beamish was a wizard who advocated
strongly for goblin rights now the fact
that he was born right in 1850 he's
guaranteed to be in hogwarts legacy and
depending on when the game takes place
maybe he'll be a student maybe he'll be
some sort of government leader or maybe
he'll just be someone we come across who
we see is advocating for goblin rights
we know that goblins were pictured in
the original leaked trailer which who
knows maybe that stuff makes it into the
game maybe it doesn't regardless i think
it's safe to say goblins will be in the
game at some point and it's very very
possible that beemish's name comes up or
we even meet the character himself
roderick plumpton was born in 1889 and
lived to 1987. he was seeker for the
england national quidditch team and the
touchshill tornadoes he holds the
british record for the fastest capture
ever of the golden snitch which was
three and a half seconds but that didn't
happen until 1921 so safe to say we
won't be seeing that in hogwarts legacy
and then we have sacharisa tugwood born
in 1874 and lived to 1966. tugwood
invented beautifying potions and
actually discovered the pimple curing
properties of bubba tuber pus i don't
even want to know about the experiments
that led to that but who knows if she's
at hogwarts while our character is
attending hogwarts it's very possible
that we could see some of this now
everything we mentioned there is pure
speculation for hogwarts legacy however
it is based on canon rooted in the
original series but if you want to see
some of the spells that we actually see
in the official trailer then check out
the video on the right side of your
screen now where i break down the
trailer and show you 10 spells that we
actually see in that trailer as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon